toy sport for his grandchildren now
ready for a refugee family jonathan
romain and his wife are preparing to
offer their spare rooms to ukrainians as
well as the two bedrooms we also want to
try and convert the
attic so we've got all they've got more
living room and space and don't have to
be dependent on us
his desire to help rooted in his own
family history my mother came over from
nazi germany as an 11 year old child and
she was a refugee and she came alone to
a strange country a language she'd never
spoken before and was taken in
under the kinder transport scheme um and
she was given hospitality wonderful
hospitality for about six months by a
quaker family in devon she's never
forgotten that i grew up with that story
about her being traumatized but also
loved by this family and how britain had
opened his arms in turn of my generation
now to step up uh in
in this disaster
as the rabbi of maidenhead synagogue
he's encouraged others to do the same
so far over 800 people have got in touch
with him from across the country as the
government's revealed there'll be no cap
on the numbers of ukrainians allowed to
come we know that there are a large
number of people in this country
generous hearted and in a position to
provide homes and businesses and to
charities as well so what we're doing is
saying we the government will act in
solidarity and in cooperation with you
we will provide not just a a payment
but we will also make sure that people
who come here have the chance to work
and get the support from the nhs from
education and from other services that
they need
this is a big bold announcement from the
government and it follows criticism that
so far they haven't done enough to help
tens of thousands of ukrainian refugees
are now expected to try to travel here
but the scheme could still be held up by
details people will need to find a
sponsor willing to take them in and
checks will need to be carried out on
both hosts and refugees
there will be government money for local
councils who need to help people when
they arrive there will be a certain
amount of trauma involved so there will
be mental health and health support
required there'll also be those normal
safeguarding issues that welcoming
and you know not not every uh matching
process will work and therefore we will
then have to step in in cases and
actually find alternate homes for people
so there's gonna be a huge amount
for councils to do
but as people prepare to welcome
refugees in the government will be
judged on how quickly they can make it
happen
becky johnson sky news maidenhead